hama est la commission spéciale sur les
droits des enfants la protection de la
jeunesse il y aurait des problèmes liés
à la politique partisane c'est ce que
nous avons appris aujourd'hui grâce à
notre collègue martin biron cette
information arrive au moment même où le
père la belle mère de la fillette dont
tragiquement à granby en avril dernier
de ce qu est l origine de cette
commission spéciale était de retour en
cour
je reçois la présidente régine laurent
présidente donc de cette commission
voulons madame leurs enfants à leurs
problèmes liés à la présence de députés
sur votre commission vsb
non c'est à dire qu'il faut comprendre
cette commission là les spéciales à plus
d'un titre
par exemple effectivement il ya repris
un député de chaque parti politique qui
est la plus les connaisseurs experts
entre guillemets et pour les députés sa
commande un devoir de réserve
donc ils ne peuvent pas parler des
travaux de la commission ne peuvent pas
publiquement non plus commenter ce qui
se passe de près ou de loin dont il y en
a trois dans d'entre eux qui ont dit
nous on va se consacrer à cette mission
lors pour les enfants dont qui nous ont
expliqué qu' il y en a que cela faisait
vraiment mal au coeur de laisser tomber
des comités auxquels elle participe et
où des commissions et il y aura
effectivement mais ces années tiki
m'applique me dire mais moi mon choix je
le fais de resté comme porte parole
santé services sociaux comme critique
services sociaux c'est correct c'est son
choix
oui monsieur legault a dû intervenir non
mais non ce n'était pas correct parce
qu'au moment où monsieur legault et les
quatre chefs étaient réunis avec
l'assentiment des quatre députés
unanimement ont demandé cette rencontre
c'était justement pour clarifier
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour chacun
des députés des partis en termes de
temps et en termes d'investissements la
commission est-ce que ça va perdre du
temps dans l'élaboration de vos travaux
parce que semble que peu de sites web en
non le site web faut comprendre que
quand on est arrivé le 30 mai après ça
il fallait tout construire et son le
construit avec les experts avec les
députés
il fallait engager du personnel et vous
savez il ya des règles au gouvernement
donc il faut à faire vous faire affaire
avec ce qu'on appelle le cspq le centre
de services partagés qui sont en train
de construire notre site web
mais on a déjà des façons où les la
population peut nous rejoindre
donc soit en faisant votre histoire
@ csd de pyj point gouv.qc.ca là qu'ils
peuvent déjà rihanna qui nous qui nous
racontent leur histoire qui veulent
intervenir au niveau de la commission
c'est une façon d'aller chercher ces
témoignages qui en même temps est ce que
si lourd à ce que c'était nécessaire
d'avoir des députés tellement différent
lorsque la protection de la jeunesse
c'est sa demande de l'expertisé des
définitions des gens qui ont vraiment
été impliqué dans ce milieu-là mentor
tout en gardant une certaine ça fait
beaucoup de monde à metz comme engrais
mais en même temps on a cinq super
expert
moi j'ai pas honte de dire que je suis
en admiration devant ces personnes-là
sur leurs expériences et expertises
c'est extraordinaire parmi nos députés
qui sont présents aussi comme
commissaire il ya des gens qui est dans
leur passé on travaillait aussi soit la
dpj auprès des enfants donc une
expertise et ça prend aussi des gens
comme moi qui a vendu recul et qui
vraiment regardons les choses d'un oeil
neuf et deux vice présidents qui ont
aussi été auprès des enfants mais
justement ça pose la question de
l'indépendance à elle été soulevée cet
été dans une lettre ouverte par un
juriste jean paul du bric quand il n'a
pas cette émission mais qui soulevait le
fait que justement il des députés des
suppléants
il y aura continuité avec les députés et
ces gens là ont été reliés à des
gouvernements qui ont mis en place le
système sur lequel vous devez faire
enquête
on espère passer de sauver la mise
sauver la réputation nous avons fait
mais c'est formidable
alors jusqu'à maintenant les rencontres
avec l'ensemble des commissaires y
compris des députés là ça ne jamais fait
partie de notre débat les gens sont
vraiment dédié à la course des enfants
on s'est croisé le mans j'ai posé la
question sur effectivement ce que vous
appelez les remplaçants et en ce moment
tous les partis sont d'accord ils sont
en train de faire des démarches auprès
du gouvernement pour qu'il reste de
façon continue et non pas se servir des
remplaçants parce que eux-mêmes se sont
rendus compte de ce que ça pouvait poser
comme problème donc scène ça n'existera
plus ce risque là si je peux dire dans
tout le monde est dédié à cette mission
là et moi là dessus je suis entièrement
d'accord avec eux en même temps parmi
vos experts il y a
cliniciens hommes il ya des gens qui
étaient encore relié au système de
protection de la jeunesse moment où ils
ont été nommés
oui des gestionnaires effectivement un
ace que ya pas trop de gestionnaire et
pas assez de gens qui ont un recul
clinique sur un sur les problèmes parce
que ces sites a été embauché comme
expert
et puis que tu vois et tenter de
cautionner les erreurs de du système
dans lequel travaillent pendant des
années c'est vraiment pas ce qui se
passe parmi les gestionnaires qui sont
là comme expert au contraire je peux
vous dire que moi je me sers de leur
expérience comme gestionnaire est ce
qu'ils sont en train de démontrer et de
nous aider dans le plan de recherche
notre feuille de route c'est de nous
pister où il ya des problèmes
ou est ce qu'il faut aller creuser
quelles sont les questions qu'il faut se
poser sont très bien placés pillent des
gens aussi qui ont été dans le réseau
des dpj et qui ont pris leur retraite
depuis un certain temps et qui
reviennent parce qu'ils veulent boucler
la boucle
ils veulent vraiment profiter de cette
commission là pour effectivement changer
les choses pour les enfants je soulève
depuis début de l'entrevue de la
lourdeur procédure ve belfond beaucoup
de commissaires c'est plus que la
plupart des commissions d'enquêté vrai
bon mais en ce moment ça nous sert ça
nous sert parce que quand on est arrivé
on avait personne y avait les deux
vice-présidents et moi la secrétaire
l'administrateur mon n'avait pas d'
équipes de recherche donc on s'est servi
dans le bon terme dans le sens du terme
de ces expertises là pour dire comment
est ce qu'on prend ça le grand mandat
très large mais il faut passer divers
défauts rentrer dans les délais donc on
s'est servi de leur expertise pour nous
aider à circonscrire le mandat et en
discuter ensuite avec les députés comme
ça vous êtes un ancien chef syndical
vous avez souvent critiqué les
institutions souvent critiqué les
gouvernements et peut-être même sur des
questions d'apparence de conflit
d'intérêts
quand on travaille même avec des experts
avec des gens qui ont un peu la patte
encore attachés à ce qu'ils ont créé est
ce que ça vous dérange d'ailleurs plus
personne avec la pâte attaché ça a été
les la commission le 30 mai il ya des
gens qui ont choisi de 10 mois je vais
prendre ma retraite très rapidement
parce que je veux travailler à cette
commission mais ces dons qui ont donné
les pays qui devrait quand même faire
une transition de façon correcte alors
les équipes indépendantes efficace la
révolution oui à la fois l'usb selon
vous absolument pas on a des bonnes
discussions par exemple vraiment parce
que c'est mon doigt qui est très large
tout le monde est avec ses émotions tout
le monde veut que sa réussite dont c'est
ce que ces passionnés par exemple on a
des longues heures de discussion très
passionnée meilleure production de
bouchons
pardon pour qu'elles se retrouveront
d'ailleurs cessé à l'internet est un
gars qui l'a tout le monde dirigeants 10
30 novembre 2020 et on veut respecter le
délai qui nous a été donné merci madame
laurent au plaisir merci